coach it's Ross Tucker filling in for
Dan and I got to tell you these guys are
kind of bumming me out this morning none
of the day Annette's are all that fire
it up for tonight's matchup they feel
like it's it's lacking a little bit are
you excited as excited as I am for
tonight I'm very excited and they should
be out here Ross the town is buzzing
everyone wants to see that Super Bowl
flag unveiled they want to see what
their new quarterback is going to do and
the Panthers side of it they're looking
for redemption and they've got a chance
to start this season out and say hey
we're going to get to want to know and
we're going to show people that were the
favorites for the Super Bowls I think
it's an intriguing matchup there there
is a lot of excitement here and I think
people are just ready for the regular
season to start yeah I'm with you I'm
I'm fired up about a Super Bowl rematch
to see what simian can do to see the the
reigning MVP I don't know what these
guys are talking about i'm curious Tony
I don't think I've ever seen Trevor
Simeon do a press conference or do
anything with the media did he sit down
with one of you guys or bob has he been
made available to you guys he actually
did he had an interview with Bob we're
going to air tonight I think people will
be interested in what they see from from
service them in and i'll tell you the
buzz here is from all their players all
their coaches that this guy you don't
know him but he has that it he has what
we're looking for they have complete
confidence in him I'm say I'm not sold
yet Ross I want to see it but everything
you hear from the Denver organization
they believe in him they expect Trevor
sent men to lead him to a Super Bowl you
know I think coach maybe just because I
was an undrafted guy I just have so much
respect for Kubiak and for John Elway
worth going with them you know it takes
some some serious guts or stones to cut
mark sanchez there's a little more of a
known commodity and go with the
second-year seventh-round pick it says a
lot about Trevor Simeon but to me it
also says a lot coach about
the confidence that Gary Kubiak and John
Elway have in themselves and their own
decision-making process to not really
care what a guy's pedigree might be it
really does Ross and you're right this
is not a team that okay we're rebuilding
and we want to get things one this is a
team that everyone knows is capable of
going to the Super Bowl and you said
okay we have a veteran player Mark
Sanchez who started a lot of games
played in playoff games has been to the
AFC Championship game we moved up in the
draft to take a quarterback number one
that we feel like is the franchise
quarterback the quarterback of the
future and we've got him on the roster
too but this guy we feel gives us the
best chance to win so that's who we're
going with and that's who we're riding
with to go to the Super Bowl I think it
takes a lot of courage I don't know that
I would be ready to do that myself to
turn a Super Bowl capable team over to a
guy who's never thrown a pass in the NFL
but they're doing it and they believe it
they totally believe it Ross talking
with Tony Dungy he'll be all over NBC
tonight football night in America is the
opening night of America's passion it's
the Panthers and the Broncos how long do
you think his leashes Tony I feel like
there's an expectation out there that
Paxton Lynch will play at some point
this year if Simeon struggles in the
first half is his short is his leash
that short that they could put Paxton
Lynch in the second half I do not think
so not from hearing these guys talk not
from listening to Gary Kubiak there
could come a time you know if they're
struggling and they're they're not
winning games or they're really
struggling on offense in October maybe
something happens but they feel like
they've got a great defense a great
running game yes Trevor Simmons going to
have to grow into this role and he may
have an off quarter an off game but they
I think he's their guy I want you to put
your defensive coordinator hat on I know
it's been a while but I want you to put
your defensive coordinator hat on you're
going against Trevor Simeon what's the
game plan and
and are you just watching preseason from
the last two years did you even maybe
have them pull some tape from
Northwestern 2014 feel the excitement I
mean what are you doing to get ready to
play against a guy that's never played
you absolutely are doing that we had
this situation when I was in Tampa we
played Dallas quincy carter started the
first game of the year and we didn't
know a lot about him we watched all the
preseason tape we watched some tape from
University of Georgia we wanted to see
what this guy was all about but the plan
is going to be very simple put the ball
and trevor some ins han Luke eakly
thomas davis at front seven you got to
do the job we've got to stop CJ Anderson
stop that running game make them throw
the ball 25 times that that's the game
plan and they don't think Trevor Simeon
can beat them throwing 25 times what
they don't want is CJ Anderson to have a
hundred and thirty yards and Denver has
180 yards rushing Trevor siemian is 94
15 for a hundred yards and they win the
game 17 to 14 they don't want that to
happen they want him to have to win the
game Tony what did you make of Ron
Rivera's complaints this week about
having to play in this opening night
game I hope he's playing possum and I
hope he hasn't aired that to him I hope
he said you know what I'm going to
complain about this but guys we want
this opportunity we want to go out there
when it's the only way you get to
guaranteed to play at home in the first
game is when your game in the Super Bowl
you win the Super Bowl you know you're
playing at home if you don't win the
Super Bowl anything could happen you
have to go where they tell you to go and
in my opinion Ron Rivera should embrace
that and say you know what we're excited
to go and show people were a better team
than we showed in the Super Bowl we're
excited to go on the road and get our
first win and we're glad we're going to
Denver that's the way I would have
approached it a couple other things
around the
league I want to get your thoughts on
the Sam Bradford trade obviously was a
huge one this week want to get your
thoughts on it from both teams
perspective and maybe in particular if
you're Mike Zimmer when do you start
Bradford you start them on sunday or do
you let Sean he'll get at least one game
i think you get sam bradford into your
building as soon as you can you pump all
the information to him he he meets with
North Turner all week and if he's ready
to go and feels comfortable operating
the offense you put him in because you
have you've told your team when you
traded a number one draft choice that
that's our guy so the sooner he gets in
there the better you're going to be now
if he's not comfortable and he goes
through yet hasn't developed a rapport
with the receivers shaun hill gives you
a better chance to win week one then you
go with Sean but you get Sam Bradford in
there week one it possible and if not we
too for sure also wanted to ask you
about Colin Kaepernick I'm just curious
Tony if he was on your roster how much
would you be embracing what is he doing
what he's doing versus being concerned
about it being a distraction for your
football team well I think you you talk
about that as a family and as a team
we're not going to have this as a
distraction we're going to be united in
supporting one of our guys and and you
know you get these all the time it may
not be something as big in this
magnitude as a national anthem but there
are things that happen that you've got
to stay together and you've got to
support each other and I think that's
what Chip Kelly is going to do that's
what they have done and the 49ers have
done it I'm sure they've discussed it
with Colin and they're ready to move
forward you'll also be in Arizona on
Sunday night as the Arizona Cardinals
host the New England Patriots and Jimmy
Garoppolo I know you've already started
to prep and study for that game as well
how do you think Garoppolo will do when
how do you think he looked in the
preseason he did a good job in the
preseason and what you have to
understand about Bill Belichick he is
the master
at doing this as taking backup players
substitutes and tailoring his system to
what they do well and minimizing their
weaknesses and yes this is the
quarterback position the most important
position on the field but he'll do it
the same way and they will and they did
it in the preseason they threw the ball
quick they used Garoppolo mobility to do
different things they will have a system
that fits him but they're going to come
out and play great defense they're going
to run the ball they're going to use
their big tight ends give them easy
throws and they're going to be fine on
offense no it's not going to be Tom
Brady everything is not going to be
relying on the quarterback but they will
have an offensive game plan that that
really highlights Jimmy Garoppolo
talents Tony have you made your super
bowl picks yet I have not I really don't
like to do that until kind of
mid-september when you get to see people
and how they mesh I'll say this you look
at Carolina and they have a good
defensive unit they've got the MVP their
quarterback is back they've got all the
weaponry to go that's who I kind of look
at who's who's got their quarterback in
plays who's got a defense that can can
get there you could look at Carolina you
look at Seattle look at possibly a Green
Bay AFC side I think you still have to
look at new england they'll have tom
brady back in four weeks pittsburgh i
think is going to be better on defense
they've got their quarterback in place
but you have to see how all that meshes
so i guess call me in a month is there
any team that you that you like to kind
of come out of nowhere like carolina did
potentially you know i living in florida
I've heard the buzz about Jacksonville I
really like Gus Bradley and what he's
brought to the table and they have they
have put pieces in place and haven't had
a great deal of success over the last
two years but the pieces are coming
together they've got a dynamic passing
game two great receivers I think they're
going to be better on defense they will
have some young defensive players I like
where Jacksonville is and
I think they've got a chance to make
some noise this year Tony thanks so much
for coming aboard the Continental Tire
coaches corner hey Russ it's great to be
with you we're happy to have Dan out
here and looking forward to tonight the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience